it's amazing to me you took your years
at harvard and you said you know what i
[ __ ] up i started guitar late i
started at 17 years old
that's right and i'm gonna sit in my
goddamn dorm room and practice eight
hours a day to unwill yourself to be a
great guitar player
you weren't a naturally gifted musician
which is mind-blowing
no one from my town had ever applied to
harvard university before so i was the
first one to ever to ever go
and so i didn't want to like kind of let
everybody down you know i
i had a calling to play rock and roll
and i knew it was a call like a full-on
zealous passionate calling but at the
same time
you know i was kind of a standard bearer
and had to you know i had to
succeed academically there as well so i
mean it
precluded any sort of social life but i
was practicing you know
four six eight hours every day without
fail without missing it i could have a
fever
of 102 an exam at eight in the morning
and i'd get my you know four hours in
not three hours and 58 minutes it was
obsessive compulsive in a way that i
don't necessarily recommend looking back
it was there was a different sort of
psychological itch that it was
scratching
and i think it had to do with control
and
you know i grew i was like the only
black person in the town
that i grew up in liberty built liberty
i literally integrate literally
integrated the town of libertyville
illinois according to the real estate
agent who helped my mom and i
with some difficulty find an apartment
there um you know and there were some
you know with some dating challenges and
and this that and the other and maybe
some you know sort of
family like i didn't meet my dad that
was 30. there's a lot of stuff but
when it came to the guitar the only
determining factor
of how that was going to go was my will
and i had my will i had will
yes you did yeah i mean well even though
you're going fast and doing these wild
things
each note is very clear and the only way
i in my mind i would get to that point
in any art
is to slowly play these scales over and
over again
yeah yeah and then it starts to move
fast but you can't start out fast right
you can't it's impossible yeah yeah and
that's the things like when the the best
advice i ever got
as a guitar player was a kid in high
school um said
you know and i was a really crappy guy
when you start at 17 there's already a
lot of guitar players who are better
than you in your high school
i mean and he just said practice an hour
a day every day
without fail and he said it as an
offhand remark and i took it to
scripture
and i did it like every day without fail
and then i saw the tide begin to rise
when i did that i said well what about
two hours a day
and i was like oh my goodness like this
is like i really do have control over
this process
first of all imagine like i'm i'm not
just practicing
hours and hours a day at harvard
university i'm a full-on metal dude like
i'm in spandex when i'm doing this
people i was like
like unicorn an insane unicorn like one
of my roommates was a
you know a pre-med one of them you know
now runs the literature department at
yale you know one of the
one was a big fan of opera and here i am
like jamming along with motley crew and
grim reaper records in my
leopard stripes spandex pants with a
bandana tight around my
thigh going yes and it's crazy because
you're at harvard and you know the
psychology of harvard is like wait i can
cash in on this degree i could get like
five
if i become a lawyer or a doctor i'd
have a choice it was like it really was
a calling